we want to defend our democracy we see
that it's under attacks
they are monopolizing social network and
they are really interfering in the minds
of individuals
[Music]
first establish a diagnosis like who is
attacking the european institutions
european democracies the european
societies with waging
informational war inside our countries
and the second part
it is medication what we should do
[Music]
this information
that is a very skillful manipulation of
human minds ideologically to push in the
direction or vote for political forces
which are not at all democratic it's
extremely dangerous i don't care if you
think that the earth is flat but if
there is a foreign government making
sure that millions of my fellow citizens
are
sure
that the earth is flat then becomes a
problem
you have armies of hackers which are
trying to enter into our institutions
all the time for instance the european
agency on medication during the pandemic
crisis or hospitals in ireland during
the crisis attacked by russian
hackers i would say that big half
particularly now in
in with the war in ukraine
the mo belongs to russia they are
employing a lot of money for this and
they are covering the vastest area
another player is china but there are
also other countries
with growing assertiveness
to
interfere
the answer will always be more democracy
the taiwan is democracy it's amazing
they are under constant attack from the
chinese regime
and instead of closing themselves up
they have built a very participative
democracy build up the resilience and
resilience means education resilience
means resources resilience means support
for media we tried to negotiate with
platforms voluntary code of
behavior our next step is
hard legislation making them responsible
for content